thank you
hi everyone welcome to this session uh
my name is lerontal also known as the
guy with the yoda hat
and uh i'm a developer advocate at sneak
on a mission to help developers
build applications securely using open
source
i'm actively working with the node.js or
the openjs
foundation on the ecosystem security
working group to help improve the state
of
security for open source node.js and npm
and javascript as a whole ecosystem
i'm involved in other application
security projects so
you're welcome to follow me on twitter
uh or visit my
my blogs on the sneak website if you
have any questions or want some
references
and we are gonna go off and i'd like to
open
up with this following questions to
ponder upon
and that is are we going to have less
or more software in the future
right are we going to use less or more
open source software in the future
so to answer these questions we need to
take another look at how
software is being constructed these days
at the very core of the applications
we're building there lies our
own custom applications code this is the
top of the iceberg you know above the
water this is the code
that we as developers can very clearly
see day to day
it's what our colleagues write it's what
you know already is
ids and what is on our focus and state
of mind
all the time so looking at these code
snippets can you
find a security issue it brings up the
question
are you aware of the security issues in
your code
as you look at the following express
middleware as is common in node.json
application
what actually is hit enter and there is
a security issue here but we'll get back
to it later
so there's the open source code that has
been there with us for many many years
beyond just our own code this is the
open source code that lies beneath the
iceberg
and we may not think about it too much
in our day-to-day
coding activities because maybe some of
it is obstructed away and we may not be
even aware of the libraries that we use
but it really makes up the majority of
the code that we write
up to 90 of these open source software
and libraries that
make up today's code in different
ecosystems like npm and ruby and maven
and most of the time when we find
vulnerabilities we find them in
open source packages that are coming
from transitive dependencies so this is
a whole new complicated world which
we'll dive into as well
but really now on open source packages
let's take a look at this code snippets
from
this popular open source library that
you might have used at one point at one
point in time in your node.js web
application
can you spot the code injection
vulnerability that hides here
once those vulnerabilities become
publicly known the first thing you want
to do
is well know about them right so you
could then take actions like
upgrade to a fixed version or maybe
patch them apply a patch if there's no
upgrade
fix maybe you want to migrate away to a
different library if needed
so here is a mental exercise summing up
a little bit of this open source world
imagine you're building an app this
could be a node.js app or something else
your mental image of your application is
focused on the
own code what you write you dwell about
it you know you spend hours debugging it
you're refactoring it and testing it
right this is something that is
very much you know the application core
of what you're building
but really the reality is a little bit
different this is the mental
exercise here that the code that we're
actually building
for this application is actually
significantly smaller
than the mental image that you have of
the application itself because
the application you're building is
actually relying on a lot of
community-powered codes
and we're leveraging this beautiful open
source world which boosts our
productivity
but need to be aware of what what's
going on there
so to put this in more perspective we
shouldn't be surprised that our
applications today
have you know may have security
vulnerabilities right we are
containerizing them there are serverless
functions
bare bones uh institute installs you
know so many ways that we can bundle
open source dependencies here and there
and therefore lies the risk
so the the use of open source is
accelerating as we're seeing
but the adoption of that the great
adoption of that comes with great
responsibility and risk as well
so we're seeing continuous growth of
vulnerabilities
in open source software in different
languages and this is growing along with
the growth of open source in general
and as users of this we need to be we
need to have the ability to mitigate
them
we need to be you know we are maybe
owning them in a way we are maintaining
or using open source software and this
is a viable risk
now taking a step you know even deeper
into this
world of open source software there is
the question
and the topic of open source supply
chain security
and i want to share an article that was
published you know not so long ago
october 2020
so very recently by the uh uh you know
by by a government right by the united
states of america the cyberspace
solarium commission
that was really advancing and then
promoting the notion of
potential compromises right from supply
chain security
and actually it calls for establishing a
center for open source software security
within government organizations
so i will give you one paragraph that i
paraphrased
out of this article which i recommend
reading and that is
dependency on adversary countries for
some or most of our critical software
supply chains
threatens to undermine the
trustworthiness of critical technologies
and components that constitute
and connect to the cyberspace so as you
can see there is a lot
of awareness in terms of what could
actually
be coming out of open source supply
chain registries and things like that
and that is why this is catching the
attention of governments you know
worldwide along with
companies and everyone else relying on
open source this is basically a
testament and acceptance of us
and evidently we've seen these security
incidents happen
time after time for example on the npm
ecosystem we've seen a social
engineering
attack and a malicious incident for this
package called the event stream that was
downloaded millions of times a week
and it demonstrated how deep the attack
surface that was
aggravated and you know by security
concerns
in nested dependencies because someone
were able to socially engineer a way
into injecting a malicious package into
this you know popular package that was
downloaded millions of times
but we have to ask ourselves have we
learned nothing
because a year after event stream
another incident took place this
electron native notify
package which targeted stealing
cryptocurrency the same as it was with
event stream
it targeted this stealing of
cryptocurrency from users who are using
the comodos agama wallet and it really
you know went through the same process
so what was going on there right
a dependency was added to a library
three weeks later that dependency
publishes
a new version with malicious payload and
three weeks after that
the agama wallet software is rebuilt and
pushed using a recent version
of electronic modifier which now
includes the malicious version
so this is how software trickles down
from supply chain into the end users to
like the build process and development
and everything else
and if that software is compromised at
any point of those stages
that is a whole story of open source
supply chain security
so another example this is this word
package name is one out of three
packages
that existed on the npm repository for
actually more than a year before someone
found out about it
and it targeted a complete system
compromise as you could see
from you know the npm staff announcement
when this was found
so leaving aside even the supply chain
security there is there are
different aspects of security
vulnerabilities for example those that
are unrelated to malicious incidents
that we all need to be aware of for
example a ui library called frapper
charts from 2020 having an xs as a
cross-site scripting
vulnerability in this front-end charting
library maybe a universal
library like urijs which has uh use
cases for both front-end and back-end
needs
but it is suffering from validation
issues so you may not be using it in a
correct way
or there is an upgraded fix that you
could use to to have
the safer version ejs a popular you know
node.js templating
library that is still vulnerable if
you're using point
uh 3.1.5 version of that which has a
high severity code injection issue
all of those which you should be you
know very well aware of if you're using
open source software
the thing is with open source we need to
do a bit of due diligence to find out
specific things about open source
packages so this advisor
you know website that you could use
gives you
this sort of health metrics around
popularity and maintenance
and security considerations and
community so you could evaluate if you
want to use a new package or an existing
one
and you have silicon tars or you want to
check what is the you know if you should
move to a different
to a different alternative or similar
package what you know what are the
options of doing that and are they
actually doing any better
so we have all of these tools but really
understanding
our dependency trees is a complicated
task even more complicated at times
is the ability to tell where wherever
vulnerability originates
and how to fix it so as an example
in the javascript ecosystem more than 80
percent of vulnerabilities that sneak
users find are in indirect dependencies
it means that even if we are looking and
watching at changelogs
and you know everything around the
direct dependency the expresses of you
know the world
what is happening is most of the time
when we find vulnerabilities they will
actually manifest
in those indirect dependencies those
transitive dependencies that
the direct ones simply you know bringing
in which is hard to track because then
we have a bigger dependency tree
so nowadays at the very least we have
bots you know automated bots that help
us
stay on top of security vulnerabilities
whether you're getting those automated
pull requests from you know sneak or
github or somewhere else that you know
that is great that you are
knowing about us but really what is what
is it telling us is
this is a message where we are entering
a world where
security is turned on by default is
something we are now used to secondly
tools
basically adapt themselves to a
developer's mindset
not the other way around and this is an
entire mind shift of how
developer security is actually and
developer first security tooling is
actually
changing the way that we interact with
with software
so developers of if we sum it up
developers often think about the
security of their application
in terms of vulnerabilities that play in
their code or in their open source
dependencies
and your open source dependency
footprint is a great way to start
you know to improve your applications
security posture
because as we've said open source
components make up to
90 of your code base but really what
lies beyond
that point right beginning with security
in open source dependencies is a great
start as we said
but we are transitioning into this
cloud-native world
where your application is really more
than your code and
what i mean by that is when we build
cloud native applications
as developers our application stack
surface
is more than just the base of the
application code
still right what is what does that
actually mean in practice so i want to
explore that with you
let's say you consistently scan your
project repositories for security
vulnerabilities you are now aware of
security vulnerabilities coming from
your code and from your open source
dependencies
so you audited you know your
dependencies and once uh
you fixed things how do you know if
you're not vulnerable to a new
vulnerability that was released after
you last scanned it
so what you actually need to do is not
just scan it as a one time off
you actually need to monitor the project
because you may have scanned it at one
point but then new vulnerabilities are
keep coming up
and are you monitoring that project all
the time to get those alerts
so you've done that but now you have a
baseline of the vulnerabilities that you
have
so as the next step hopefully you even
got to a really really good
baseline point where you have maybe a
few or even zero vulnerabilities in your
projects
i want to say congratulations amazing
job which it is
but there's a bit of a misconception
here and that is what i want to
highlight
uh specifically in this talk and that is
our application repository is
continuously scanned for vulnerable
dependencies
this is great but it is not the complete
picture it is not
it's not capturing the whole story
there's the issue of potential
dependency parity drift
which are deployed artifacts and you
know that is right it means that we
don't just develop applications
to build them and save them in the
repositories main branch
we also deploy them and there could be a
drift of of
different of different states between
the dependencies in the deployed states
and the dependencies in the in the main
repository branch and that is the drift
that i'm talking about here
so you know this is where the next layer
of our story actually reveals itself
in a pre-cloud world we deployed on bare
metal servers we deployed
on you know maintaining our own
infrastructure
we had hopefully you know achieving
elasticity and some flexibility with
virtual machines
but you know these days you know who
even who even remembers those days or
care about the overhead of maintaining
your own infrastructure because we have
entered into a cloud era
right this says we are living it we're
not just centered we are
the factor there so it means that if you
build a small api
maybe you go ahead and deploy it as a
serverless lambda function if you build
a front end
you may deploy it on a netlife reversal
as you know cloud front-end
infrastructure and they they worry about
all the ssl and the caching and the edge
deployment and the atomic deploys you
give them that
concern and they manage that for you
this is the cloud if you maintain
several micro services it's natural to
fill the way
the urge to wrap them up in a container
and deploy them to the cloud
right and let's let's focus on that
specific part this is the whole cloud
native part this is
containers for example as one of those
examples that i've
said before are you know an easy topic
because it can easily relate to that it
gives us you know cross
a platform compatibility to deploy no
matter what cloud you're running on
uh it is faster and more lightweight to
spin up those than
vms it provides you this uh reproducible
application environment
so for all of those reasons we could
talk about containers so let's dive
deep into this and now try to fill those
blanks
we talked before about all our
application our application dependencies
and our application dependencies are not
running in a vacuum right they are part
of somewhere this this gets deployed
somewhere
don't just write code for the sake of
writing code and so
now this blank space i think becomes
clearer because
if we're sticking to these examples of
docker containers here
an application that we containerize as a
docker application for example this
node.js application
it suddenly tells us how our attack
surface grows
in ways that i'm sure you may have not
think uh taught about before
so let's break it down and see what
attack surface is now being
more of a concern for us as a developer
for example this is a docker file which
i can
go ahead and show you how we actually
have a docker file for a node
application and what actually
hides in it so what are we actually
bringing in this node.js image if i'm
bringing
you know if i'm saying from node you
know under different
bad practices here right so this is just
for the sake of simplicity and brevity
kind of small
but uh what if i'm doing from node what
os dependencies am i bringing
pulling into my dependency into my
application and do i need all of them
you may need some specific tools and
libraries available on the container for
the application to function properly so
maybe you want to convert images so
maybe do opt-get install image magic
because you choose to spawn a system
command that uses image magic library
that
is available on linux distributions like
you know like node is based on ubuntu
or debian so this common software makes
up your container
and well potentially it increases your
application attack surface now
i understand that at this point maybe it
seems like well how do you
you know connect the dots between a
vulnerability that someone is able to
exploit
you know from the other side of the
application into
a dependency that is running on the
container itself that could
be vulnerable well i'm going to show you
how we do it in a live hacking session
quite soon we're going to go see all of
this unfolds
but more in this docker file you know
what what lies in the right the version
of the dependencies
in deployed containers can be
significantly different from what you
have
even scanned and monitor in your
repository because deployment
doesn't necessarily mean that it is the
same thing that you had in your
repository because of the drifts
so if you're not installing dependencies
in the same time and you're not fixing
them and you're not pushing those
security fixes you know right on time
you may have those disparity drifts but
really the thing that i think
people are missing a lot in terms of
understanding the containers
you know the container side of
vulnerabilities is not the actual
vulnerabilities in in the in the
container itself but actually the
runtime
when you're doing from node right which
version
are you actually pulling in do you know
which version actually running in
production
do you know if it is vulnerable or not
because this is the node runtime this
is what people have direct interaction
from the outside of the application to
the node
application itself that you've built so
it's meant that if there's a
vulnerability in the node.js runtime
well that is directly impacting your
application
and node.js vulnerabilities do happen
you know
time to time so you need to be aware of
this now there's a good reason we're
talking about containers here
as an example because this race to the
cloud that we also
you know often referred as this digital
transformation
has accelerated the use of container
technology
and what it means is that these problems
this problem space of using
safe base images isn't very intuitive
for us to figure out
so what is happening as an example here
is we are consistently you know year
after year at stake
we've seen that the top 10 docker base
images on docker hub are carrying
security vulnerabilities in them by
default so just by using the default
node base
image you're actually introducing you
know 500 or 600 vulnerabilities
maybe more maybe less and this is this
is just by getting that from node
image so let's hack an application right
let's go into this
live session where i will take you
through a process of how we're
exploiting
an open source library called marked
which is a markdown library that i use
to build an application a to-do
application
you can see kind of like how how it is
used between the application logic
and how it's used in the view to render
data and we're going to take even a step
further we're going to
hack an application based on the fact
that we have a vulnerable dependency in
it specifically
image magic as a way to convert images
on the container itself on the
application
even more i'm going to show you how we
are able to hack into an application
based on a vulnerability that exists in
a node version in a node.js runtime
itself so
hopefully you're ready for that and i'll
be happy to have that uh session run as
like an interactive one so if you wanted
to take part if you wanted to ask
questions
if you wanted to engage i'll be asking
you know here and there uh some you know
for you some hints
uh go ahead and use the q a box to just
submit some questions for us and i'll be
trying to uh
do the live hack and monitor that at the
same time and we'll be able to uh
have a bit of an interactive session
here so to get us started what i'll do
first
is run the app
so for that we need to
run mongodb as the database for the
application
uh just a lot of logs which we don't
care about but we go here and
as we know that the app is run the
database is running fine i'll be running
the app
it's available on port 3001 so we could
go there
there we go and we have the app running
so as i said this is basically now for
us
a way to start investigating what is
wrong with this application because it
has
a vulnerability in it that has a
dependency that has the vulnerability in
it
so this says you know us we could say
you know hi linux foundation
folks right and it has
marked which is a markdown library so
i've started here before in this uh
advisor thing
which gives me a really good health
score you know 100 uh 100 this is pretty
great
it's pretty perfect anyway um this is
five almost five million weekly
downloads this is getting you know
really great
numbers so i'll use this it looks you
know very maintained very healthy
and this is what i'll use and i've
already added this to our project
so you can see here i've required it in
the top in my require file and then
and then we have a marked set option
sanitize true so this is interesting
from different perspective first of all
if i hadn't done that what it meant is
if i hadn't initialized like marked with
any specific
uh well sanitized or other options
what would happen is it would actually
uh initialize
in an unsafe manner so at this point
i am going to uh you know put all the
security
you know uh um gates that i can in here
you know this is where i'm exposing it
to the view and you know later on it is
it is showing up there
so it could be things like maybe you
want to add links like this isn't good
examples of markdown right you can do
something like this
and there we go we have markdown turned
into a link so this
is the capability that we wanted to get
from this markdown uh
library which is of course i'm not going
to use you know write my own markdown
parser so i have this and this is like
the greatness of open source
next i will try to exploit it so any
ideas on
what we could try next to maybe exploit
this vulnerability
would you maybe try something like this
as
one hint and as i said you could feel
you could feel uh engaged to just put
something in the q
a if i try that what do you think will
this work
that's right well it didn't work it's
not working because we're sanitizing
remember we said we're going to sanitize
all this input that we're getting so
marked has this logic that anything that
it gets it's going to try to sanitize it
away
so this didn't really work too well i
can try something else for example i
know that
true links i can also add javascript so
i could try something like this
let's see if this works javascript alert
okay so this is almost there we're
trying to create a next success across
side scripting vulnerability here based
on the fact that
maybe the marked library that we're
using is vulnerable um
this doesn't work and there's a reason
why it isn't working because
of the fact that because of the fact
that
uh there are regexes inside the marked
source code
that remember we said sanitize through
so it's looking at all of those
uh you know things that we're trying
like javascript call on something and
it's
you know sanitizing them away and i've
got this great answer here from
david acosta thank you we can try html
encoded characters which means
i can if it's looking for javascript
columns something like any function that
goes from it i can represent colon in a
different way
and these are called html entities so i
can do something like this
uh and 41 is the closing here and i
cannot try and represent
stuff that i know as you know maybe
looking at the source code of marked i
know they need to
escape from them so let's try that and
see what happens
almost almost this is a great direction
david thank you
so for us what it means is it's not
really game over because
we can still try more things right
marked is open source so i can see what
the actual regex is trying to look at
and i know there's another rejects
because
it looks for html entities so like the
maintainers were thinking about this and
they had like great
you know security mindset here which is
amazing so
this is this is great but what's what's
actually missing what is
what what kind of like you know the
security bug here the vulnerability of
manifests is
if i if i'm going to represent and i'm
going to make a slight change to the
html if i'm going to use
this uh this document or even like this
as like a javascript you know this is a
valid javascript keyword
right if i use that this doesn't make
sense
as you know the whole string here
doesn't make sense as an html entity so
it passes the sanitization process and
that is where the flow is at
so it passes it and this you know mark
says you know this is fine whatever you
want with it just put it on the screen
but the browser treats it as a different
way maybe the browser allows this to
actually execute javascript so let's try
well first of all we're seeing uh to
remind you like this is what we've
just added and you can see that now we
have a link
and if i click on it then at this point
we have basically
had this uh you know established our
exercise this is the cross-site
scripting
vulnerability that happens in marked in
an open source library having millions
of downloads
in this version that i'm using that i
know is vulnerable for this you know
demonstration purposes but it is a real
vulnerability in an open source package
and this exploit for it is live now
there's an interesting you know story
here between this this library which is
why i like you know repeating on this
specific vulnerability because there's a
story of open source here
and you know let's go through this so if
i go into my
vulnerability database uh you know over
here and i
let me filter this for npm and i'll go
ahead and do mark i want to search for
this one specifically
see it had over the times you know you
know different kind of
even 2020 and uh you know i think i saw
something on 2021 as well
last time yeah so even 2021 not so long
ago different kind of vulnerabilities
that we know we should be aware of
uh but this one specifically which was
you know fairly a few years back
was discovered by matt austin and
i want to show you what happens here
because the way that it was discovered
is they opened this this open source
pull request to this
repository now saying there's an
exercise suite no uh
vulnerability here and there's like a
great report and you know people are
thumbs up right because this is a pool
because it's not just an issue telling
you know
annoying the maintainer you know hey
there's an issue fix it this is really
helpful this is for me at the meeting
when i want to merge this right this is
it has tests and and uh and like for
regression testing
and it has uh the fix itself as well
like everything is here for me just to
go ahead and fix it
but as is with open source right
maintainers have their own lives and we
can't expect them to
hold them accountable for all of those
things and this is part of the open
source story where
maybe maybe a pull request got opened in
2015 but yet
only got uh merged or released to
production even if it's a security issue
you know a year later and this this is
the problem right so there are ways to
you know what do you do
when you have this problem right what do
you do when you cannot upgrade a library
there's like no upgrade for this library
at you know war at that point in time so
snake has this cool stuff like you know
there's a patch
uh and all of this is like fully
available you could you know you could
just you know view it and use it to
continue the whole
uh stick building if you didn't want to
uh but we make it available so this is
for you
um now a patch that we take and you
could just you know run like a sneak cli
uh command sneak patch and if you have
this it will go ahead and apply that
patch if there's no no
upgrade fix so this is a great story of
like how open source connects how you
know we
you need to be on the bleeding edge
sometimes there are no upgradeable fixes
which is you know a whole story of
itself but it's this is the story
so hope you're having fun uh let's let
let's let's take this app aside you know
and say you know hey let's
this is running you know on my dev
machine you know this is just npm run
start on my
uh dev machine let's go ahead and do run
something in a container and you know
if we had bundled an object application
container what could go wrong so
i'll go ahead and stop here my one going
to be i'll go ahead
stop the app i see that it stopped and
i've got some slides
of screens ready here so i will start
with
first of all as we need to do first um
build a container but i want to show you
first what is going on there so
as we go over here we can see the actual
uh container itself so this is my app
it's a very small application the whole
thing that it does this node app that i
deploy to production on on a
containerized um
instance is um i want to convert an
image so i have this upload route
that all of the app is exposed from this
slash public um
route as well and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to spawn a command because
i do not want to block the thread for
the node.js application
to do anything like uh you know
synchronous here so i'm going to use
this
um i'm going to use this convert
application that is built and available
as image magic is on my container and
then you know just go ahead and
and resize the image this is my docker
file it's pretty straight i didn't even
have to install image magic this is just
apparently it's available in this node
image and yeah we're taking now uh you
know the the
the the time train we're traveling back
in time back to where note 6 were alive
and if think about it fewer running node
applications back then as well
you know what could have happened so
this is just picking you know some uh
you know some node image tag here
and all of this is you know pretty
pretty pretty simple so i'll go ahead
and do
docker build which i've done before but
it's always great to see that this is
up to date and then i want to run this
application so i've got
this one
different board there we go so this is
going to run on this port and i call it
rce
you know what nrc that should give you a
hint of like what is going to go
on here so let's let's leave this up and
move into
this one okay so a new application as i
said
everything exists on slash public so i
will open that and as you can see this
is allowing us you know hello there
upload an image to convert this so i can
go ahead and upload the conversion of
images
so maybe i'll go ahead and choose one
and i've got a few of them ready so
hopefully you've uploaded something to
social media i have something called
rce1.jpg i mean that's that's just fine
or it should be fine right but before i
do that i want to go into
the container itself and tell you why
that that might be an issue so
let's go in and see first of all i will
find my running container here and crc
one
and connect it and at this point on this
side of the screen
i want to show you the files that
actually this is deployed in user source
goof
remember that's what we had um over here
user source google this is the place
where we deployed the application
on this is the working directory on the
container itself on the os
and these are the files that exist in
and this is you know what i showed you
before the server.js everything there
even the docker file is there
this is not the best practice but this
is great for our demo
purposes so i have it here and what i
want to do is
resize this picture which is you know
what makes sense as
you know maybe that you want to build so
looks like it's over looks like it's
done and we have resized our
applications but what is going on let me
show you
a difference here so as you can see on
the right side here
my my directory here is a little bit
changed in terms of output
of what you see here specifically what i
want to call out is there's this new
file
called rce1 that was created on the
running container
which did not exist before as you can
see on the top of it now why did that
happen
this is because we have an exploit oh
there we go i'm already on the exploit
directory
and i will cut rce1 and show you what's
going on there
so essentially what we have is
you probably you know haven't seen this
one before it's not a very common
uh way to create jpeg files but it is
supported it is
a way that image magic is a library like
i said a tooling for uh you know for
linux
uh to basically allow you to manipulate
images in different ways and it has this
feature called
delegates where you could have not
binary data but declarative text data
that tells
you how to build the image tells the
conver the image magic library to how to
do it you have to create an
image you you know define a resolution
you say you know fill the image based on
the this other source which you could
you actually can provided this url
source to do it you know over the wire
or something
but what it has is a vulnerability that
does not check does not validate that
this could be
because this is offloaded to another
command that
image magic spawns it doesn't validate
that this is a specific you know
url and not something else but it what
it does is it takes that you know we
take it exploits that vulnerability
and actually it appends to it or adds to
it
this command execution that is touch rca
one touch is a
is a unix command that creates a file
called rce1 and that's why we have it
here with the size of zero because we
just touched it we just created
nothing else except that but by the fact
that we were running
a vulnerable version of a dependency in
a container right this is this is
nothing to do
with the application itself the fact
that we had a vulnerable version
of a container here of a dependence
heater image magic which may
you wouldn't know about it at all if
you've seen this one this had introduced
a vulnerability here that we have
exploited
and you know the code here there's no
issue with it with the dependencies here
there's no issue with like you know code
security issues here that allowed that
to happen this is just the fact
that we have relied on a specific
dependency
in a vulnerable container now how do you
manage all of those things so
if you were talking about um you know
scanning your applications right this is
the
you know me scanning this goof
application that i showed you before and
this is the dependencies right so i can
see the dependency tree i can look at
you know other dependencies
remediation and i can see that marked is
you know having
vulnerabilities in it and i can go ahead
and fix this and if i do it you know
i'll get this automatic pull request
that fixes it
uh if i don't you know if you just set
it up to just fix your dependencies
but this is a great way of understanding
your dependency tree and all the
problems that happen from it
uh you know but even more interestingly
is you know the ability to know how to
remediate this problem from
you know what do you need to upgrade and
what problems does it solve the other
thing is the container side right we've
we're running node
six or the specific base image of it
which has 800 vulnerabilities again
if i look for image magic that's here so
what do i do with all of those i know uh
what is it like hundreds of
vulnerabilities in image magic how do i
know what to move into
so maybe something gives me an advice
what to move into but i'll get to that
in a second because
i showed you how we can do it from the
from the from the uh the upside
and the container side but actually i
want to take it a little bit further
i want to talk about what happens when
the node runtime
is problematic so what i mean by
problematic is you know vulnerable
so for us to make that uh to make that
happen what we need to do is first of
all build a container so
let's say you know that now node selects
is vulnerable
so i'll go out of this and i'll first of
all start
i stop my containers uh my container is
running here
there we go all stopped and i will go
ahead now and say hey
um you know this is remember this is us
back in time back in the days where
there was note 6 and maybe you had that
running
in some micro service and you're saying
well you know now this is have like a
new version like
the new lts is eight right let's use
node eight let's use node eight
zero five that's like the newest it's
like the latest version of this table it
has all the fixes everything in it
maybe maybe it doesn't i don't know but
you could have made that decision to
move from node six
to node eight five zero let's see what
happens when we do that
so i will go ahead and need to now
rebuild this
this the same app we're going to rebuild
it so docker build
there we go
yep done so once we've rebuilt it the
uh the docker image now we can go ahead
and run it we're gonna do the same thing
as we've done before
this is the same app let's see if this
works
okay this is the same app and you know
it now doesn't really have the other
vulnerability of image magic because
we have used a new version of image
magic in that you know node 8 5 0.
so we have migrated out of one
vulnerability but what happens
with the node runtime itself which is
another concern that you should have
so if you're using slash public maybe
you want to try different ways of you
know runtimes have
issues some of them could be you know
redos attacks or you know just denial of
services of different kinds
of or maybe you know https related
issues and you know
leaking of information and things like
that like memory issues and stuff that
have been
also hitting node in the past one of the
other things could be a patch reversal
that may be drawn
the runtime is not managing that
correctly so what we could actually do
here is
you know try and traverse this tree like
that which as you can see doesn't really
work
too well if i do it from here but
if you have any idea how i can do it
from here
let me see i'm going through my my
question box to you okay
go ahead and suggest but i'll just go
run into it with this
in the meanwhile and that is maybe i
want to go ahead and
and try something similar to what we did
with mark which is
i'll go ahead and url encode those dot
dots so a dot
is the two percent e so two percent e
and you can see i've already like tried
this a while ago and this
is basically the way for me to traverse
the tree of the directories back
inside as if this was running inside of
of the container itself so the container
has the slash public as the root
directory but we want to traverse far
out of it because we want to see the
package json we want to see the you know
dot end
file that you may have api keys we want
to see uh you know different things that
you know might be telling us you know as
attackers for this might be telling us
you know more information on how we
could hack in
so the way that we're doing it is we're
basically you know two percent day two
percent
we're now traversing up the tree we're
using a bit of a
of a logic magic here
to to exploit a vulnerability related to
patch reversal in the node.js runtime
and if i run it this is basically now
the output
of the etcd sorry the atc
password of the running container of the
node
inside like this node application so i
this is nothing to do with
dependencies on the container this has
nothing to do with
my my code being bad like over over here
nothing to do with this
i've basically just created a public
route here with express
known framework for node.js but i am
taking advantage of exploiting a
vulnerability in the node.js runtime so
this is
the case of traversing from the top to
the bottom
and i want to go back into our slides
and continue this story
so hopefully that was fun right but what
can i do about it and i'm pretty sure
that this says you know kind of like you
know what could i do with this
but first of all i want to give you you
know a bit of like references here so
what we've what we've exploited on the
container side was this improper input
validation
a cve you know a vulnerability report
that came out for image magic and this
is you know very very real
uh but it is also very easy to miss as a
problem
first of all like the cvss score is not
like a 10 right which is shouting
uh the cde report doesn't mention you
know remote command execution or
whatever you could do it is this is just
important for
input validation and it looks as if this
is you know
maybe not so not so um significant but
as you saw it is i could run
commands on the running container and to
give you an example of like why i
chose specifically to use a story here a
demonstration that uses image magic and
node.js to spawn commands because this
is something that people do this is
something that people may
may do as like a job server or something
else and this is like a screenshot i got
from youtube of a video from
google i o you know 2017 event where
they demonstrated you know a similar
capability you know lived around the
stage
you know doing the exact same thing
right so this is a very common
uh you know way to do things like
converting images if you wanted to
but we need a way to to help developers
understand that we need you know why do
developers you know
think that that could be vulnerable so
like like an application to image magic
so tooling like this makes it easy right
it shows you this layer
of you know layer level indication of
where this is coming from this says
maybe me doing apt-get install image
magic and if it's coming from somewhere
else like the base image it will tell
you
it correlates the docker file run and
whatever directives you have there
with the actual vulnerabilities
themselves so you know where to look for
the problem itself
but even so right so how do you fix it
like i told you there's a there's like
you know 862 vulnerabilities in this
node
10 image what do you do about it i i
searched docker hub
before and it has almost 4 000 different
node image types which one should you
move to to 10 5 to 10 16 to 12
something you have no idea right and
this is where we're trying to be helpful
so you have no idea if a new version is
going to be you know having you know
more vulnerabilities less what's going
to happen there
this is where the tooling really helps
you this is where developer first
security
really shines because it gives you this
data based
recommendation that tells you hey there
are this is the image that you're using
862 vulnerabilities
but you can move into a different you
know kind of like base image you could
upgrade
to maybe node 12 or you could just stay
at node 10 but use an alternative you
know image that's like a little bit
smaller has less dependency footprint
maybe that's just enough for you to run
your applications so
you know we talked about chord right you
writing your own code like this kind of
lines of code of
what i had and we talked about using
open source dependencies and the
the you know the issues that they may
have and we talked about your container
right and your dependencies
runtime uh as well all of this that
we've talked about but what did we miss
out
you talked about all of those things but
how do you deploy how do you deploy and
orchestrate your applications
you know in production in deployment
time that that's the thing right there
right we have commoditized
infrastructure in the form of code and i
can hear you know the thoughts in your
brain running around you know asking me
for examples what i mean by that so
let me show you your infrastructure as
code whether you're doing kubernetes day
to day whether you're
using you know docker whether you're uh
you know a google compute fan using
firebase
maybe you're a you know front-end
developer deploying to you know to the
cloud to
you know the front-end cloud if you've
ever run any of these commands in the
past
then you have taken advantage of
infrastructure as code
and you are effectively now hello you
yes
you are a cloud native application
developer and that means you need to
basically concern yourselves with
everything related to cloud native
application security
and this is really the last piece of
this puzzle right this is the bottom of
the iceberg an entire application
orchestrated using the power
of code and why are we even discussing
you know
these kind of things right because these
are nowadays you know the cloud
infrastructure that has been
completely abstracted a ways uh you know
from you know
anything the hardware based into into
the form of code where we can deploy it
as fast as we're deploying code we're
deploying
infrastructure at the same time those
mistakes that we make in
configuration are the number one cloud
vulnerability as is identified by the
nsa
so let me give you some examples for
this this is a firebase configuration
that adds a rule so that only
authenticated users can
view or create documents this is a you
know this is a good story that i have
from like a real live application
it's a really use case where this was
the security configuration because
what's going on here
there is no authorization implemented
there is authentication but notarization
so the fact that this is you know there
for you built you know by default
doesn't mean that it's you know with
security by default enabling and
protecting you
and maybe you have disabled uh sorry
maybe you have uh
enabled only uh specific users to log in
but you
forgot to disable registration all of
those
are really ways for someone else that if
you have done
any cloud-based configurations here for
them to basically exploit those
uh those uh you know concerns that you
have missed
i'll take you to a kubernetes example
it's where this is a partial kubernetes
symbol file that will deploy a pod
that the you know the full you know this
is just part of it but the full one
deploys just fine
the only problem is it's missing out
some crucial security related hardening
that is not
turned on by default one of those issues
with kubernetes is this thing called the
security context which
if you are missing it then it allows you
to run application without root user
control
and this bud level you know directive
now fixed it the fact that i added it
but
i have no idea like i'm not a kubernetes
engineer i'm just a developer so
how do i know if i have more issues i
don't know about dishes like who knows
this stuff
so that's why we need again those
developers security platforms because
they point out the issues
in the form that we developers
understand them and that they are
showing us how to fix them and you know
why are they even happening and where
they happening you know within this code
because like everything has now been
abstracted away into that form so
uh i would like to leave you off with
you know several takeaways here right
one of them is you know connect your
source code repositories to continuously
scan them
i want you to connect your container
image registries always you can
continuously scan them as well
and have this uh you know not have that
riff like continuously monitor what you
have deployed
as well as what you have in your source
code repositories if you can you know
prefer minimal based images
cure based images however you're
managing those but you know be able to
act with
some kind of image based image
recommendation advice or you if there's
a vulnerability that comes into life
you know where to move to very fast
and lastly you know don't forget your
infrastructure it is just as vulnerable
and take measures to monitor it and fix
it
so this is our session i want to you
know uh
you know wish you a safe journey here in
this like cloud idea of application
security space because you're all
cloud native application developers and
uh there are some resources here and
we'll show them there's like a lot of uh
security cheat sheets on how to do
things
uh the right way in different contexts
of technologies you can find them on
this
sneak i o dot slash uh blog and with
this i'll go ahead and
let's let's go to the questions say some
of them are already there
so i'll go ahead and go through uh some
of them thank you for these questions uh
first one
was how are dependencies marked how
often do you upgrade
marked okay so i'm gonna assume this was
based on
uh the marked dependency here
which you may have got that we have this
plugin that shows you when you type
something in it kind of like annotates
this
uh this is if i got the question right
like how do we you know annotate that
this is based on this one cost plugin
and how often do you update to marked so
well if there's another there's
the context of you know being on the
bleeding edge but also
you know being very wary of being on the
bleeding edge is important because
sometimes you could just be a victim of
malicious security incidents like we've
had before with event stream
and eslint scopes and others um so you
want to automate that process through
things you know like
like the sneak tooling that helps you
upgrade those and we have inherently
added
this kind of like artificial delay or
even if the
version is out it will it will take it
will
delay the upgrade you know as a specific
amount of time
that we have observed from other recent
incidents security incidents
that you know uh took time to uh to to
find those issues so
that's how we automate it away you could
do that or you could like use something
like a sneak cli if you needed to like
automate whole workflow based on your
own um
processes and uh and pipelines
that that's this one uh what else how
about container registry in
enterprise cobalt to reduce
the security vulnerabilities um
so container registries not sure about
google specifically but if you have
container registries what i'm suggesting
here is if you
this is basically this takeaway which i
don't know if this was uh
there before but if you connect those uh
container registry wherever you host
them
um whatever cloud infrastructure into
into what you monitor like your
application uh you know security
monitoring thing
then you can actually see those uh
serious vulnerabilities in runtime
and runtime meaning here not to run down
with the container but like
when when we find new vulnerabilities
that's where we will tell that's when we
will tell you
uh of this stuff happening so for
example i'm monitoring
monitoring here this uh uh this is from
uh
from docker hubs as you can see the
source i've connected this i have this
image here
and anytime you know um we're going to
scan this on a daily basis
and anytime there's going to be new
vulnerabilities or maybe new
recommendations to upgrade
to different versions you can see for
example if you move from node 6 which is
super old
you know end of life you can move into
different uh you know note 14 which is
long-term support and this is a great
way for us to basically uh
win this uh uh when this you know less
vulnerabilities uh
you know attack surface so it tells us
how to do this and this is kind of like
the
the way to to connect what we're having
on the
the image registry and what we actually
want to have
running in production as well in a safe
way
great question um so if this thing this
is maybe the last one
uh does this feature infrared code
kubernetes template scanning
works with helm yes so um
that has answered live thank you for
that one so we have support for that
uh that's already out and you could
probably take a look at the sneak plug
and other resources on the sneak website
to see
um both roadmap of you know what's
coming next uh
helm is supported um and uh and
and you know the kubernetes xml file as
well
more information is definitely is
definitely there uh being accurate on
like the timing and releases and the
exact feature
completeness that we have there uh but
yes this is
uh let me take that screenshot back
again
and uh this is basically the
kubernetes.tml file that we are
i'm showing here the screenshot
all right so i think we are going to
wrap up
thank you for all the questions uh hope
you enjoy it and i hope
uh you're gonna be uh stay safe using
open source software
great thank you so much to lauren for
his time today and thank you to all the
participants who joined us
as a reminder this recording will be on
the linux foundation youtube page later
today
we hope you're able to join us for
future webinars have a wonderful day
you